hey guys this is made from Tim Garvey
I'm Gary's international strategist and
community manager today I'll be working
with Jim to explain the content model
through this four DS this portion is
like with me so I think this is one you
need to get selfish like you'd ask your
question
hiring is guessing firing is know like
you got to go fast
that's how you get [ __ ] done that's a
bigger step out this is the television
and the television is the radio for
these [ __ ] so what we're gonna
do now is walk through six different
moments that we pulled out from this
episode and we're going to explain to
you like why we picked them why we
didn't pick them how we reimagine them
for each platform and what the impact of
those were at the end of this episode I
value the trenches and people value the
ivory towers and that is why nobody
scares me so before we're going to
explain how we use a Content model I
actually want to explain what the
content model is so the content model is
actually a pillar piece of content that
we use to break into individual smaller
pieces of content we use the pillar
content to reuse reshape reformat so we
can fit into different platforms now the
content model itself is actually
available to everyone right now it's a
free 86 page deck that is available on
Geary be calm slash content model so now
we're gonna dive into how we use the
content model and how you can use as
well buying the New York Jets is my
ambition the process of trying is my
happiness so for this clip we actually
had four titles that we meaning Gary and
the team came up with when we present on
Twitter we actually showed a raw clip
with subtitles on it over 50% of the
audience don't listen with sound on so
this is the first way that we engage the
audience second we actually use the poll
options on Twitter which has a 25
character limit and we presented the
four titles in a sequence and we let the
community choose which title they like
this by engaging our audience we're able
to create a ripple effect among our
community one they get to participate in
content for Gary so that hides them up
too we give them early exposure to the
piece of content so when the full thing
comes out which is the full pillar
content people will feel more excited
and more familiar with that piece of
content and 3 it helps our audience feel
special because this is actually an
exclusive piece of content that we
haven't shown to anyone else meanwhile
the entire company's out of here at 6
p.m. except my team I don't require my
employees to live the same framework I
live we're always looking for strong
actionable messages and in this one
there's a little bit of a twist so when
we when Gary says hey the entire
companies out at 6 o'clock we think our
users are gonna find that kind of
interesting giving Gary's work ethic
which is so legendary the second part
about this is that we framed this clip
to appeal to two different audiences one
being the employer that's doing the
hiring and firing but the second is from
the employee who's often misunderstood
as someone who doesn't work hard enough
when Gary stands up for the employee we
found that that's been very well
responded to I grew up in the alcohol I
owned weed library calm in 1997 so in
this clip Gary actually talks about
owning weed library calm in 1997 I've
been on cannabis but I'm not a cannabis
expert I'm patient and thoughtful and
pay attention I don't need to brand
myself as an expert or like or give me
people literally that we all know on
Twitter or other things have in the last
four years been a social media expert a
blockchain expert and a cannabis expert
and there's nothing wrong with chasing
news I mean there's a lot of quick money
to be made and I don't judge it's just
not what I'm interested in and so timing
matters to me and so for example if
we're gonna go live practical on the
blockchain conversation we've got a long
way to go so we ended up not using this
clip because Gary
jumped from this topic that we wanted to
use into a different topic and that in
turn helped us realize like oh he didn't
finish his thought process and we didn't
want to just put this out and not
provide enough value to our audience
Instagram especially has just captured
so many people of a generation
they literally post to maximize likes so
Gary often tackles topics that others
shy away from so when he does that we
like to take that opportunity to answer
a really important question that people
are often afraid to ask when we build
Instagram clips we do it in a very
specific way there's four things we try
to include with almost every every video
the first being a hook and that's a
three to five second video clip that we
move to the front of the video to
capture people attention as they're
scrolling through the feet when I post
that I get 4,000 likes but when I post
my ass or my boobs I get 15,000 and I
can't stop next we include the Sonic
branding tag this is something that we
include on every clip it's a mandatory
requirement because Gary's very high on
the future of voice and this is how
we're gonna establish our branding on
all the videos that we have out there
makes me craft the title that provides
actionable advice that's something that
we've seen our audience responds really
well to when gary provides motivational
actionable guidance and instruction on
how to do something instagram especially
has just captured so many people of a
generation they literally post to
maximize likes they've killed their own
creativity people start creative on
Instagram when people start following
them and then they become a robot of the
machine because they know it's you know
attractive women young women ask me
secretly like at a conference or at a DM
of like I really know a lot about health
and wellness but when I post that I get
4,000 likes but when I post my ass or my
boobs I get 15,000 and I can't stop and
I'm like okay how about not having your
self-esteem wrapped up and how many
likes you get on Instagram but but it
becomes the Machine our call to actions
are really important because it is the
closure of that video and we really hope
that users after watching this video
will take action it's the chord every
message that Gary has is to do so we try
to close with some specific direction as
to what you should be thinking about or
doing that
I would be a top-five sportscaster in
our society right now if I started I
know a lot about sports I know how the
framework works bigger than Stephen a
Smith I promise as you can see it's
actually a tick-tock clip Gary's been
super bullish about tick-tock and we
want to make sure I'm moving forward any
clip that we ingest that we actually
think about the platform what we did was
actually going to tick-tock and find a
trending song that could match this
moment once we found that song we
actually did our own version and our own
editing of that song in Adobe Premiere
once we finished the whole packaging of
that clip we exported it into tik-tok
and actually chose the same song in
tik-tok but muted it so the algorithm on
tick-tock would know that hey we use the
song but we actually just had our own
version on top of it
podcast excites me for a lot of reasons
because it's a triple arbitrage in this
clip Gary gives very tactical advice so
when he does that we really like to take
advantage of it and build it out in
extensive ways but one you get the
podcast and people are listening in the
world today and what we love about audio
is when you're on the treadmill or
walking the dog you can consume passive
audio consumption is going to continue
to compound in value to you film the
podcast which gives you an ungodly
amount of post production capabilities
yet one motherlode pod you know piece of
content for your YouTube and Facebook
video
you could then get the potential have
six to nineteen pieces of other content
that come from a moment or two and then
the third arbitrage of the thurible
arbitrage is your guests I'm doing
something right now that's super
interesting I've posted a question for
Mark Cuban and yesterday I posted a
question from Shawn Mendes both
over-index did both over a million views
on Instagram which is a high watermark
for me because their brand equity weight
and if you hire a writer you're actually
quadruple Arbitron so now you can turn
it into written form the transcription
which led me to what ended up being the
Holy Grail
I'm gonna just [ __ ] fill myself as
often as humanly possible and post
produce in this case we've built three
different pieces of content one being a
cartoon that we published a LinkedIn
that summed up the concept in a really
short punchy way the second being an
Instagram clip which we assigned as a
heavy hitter for the day and so a heavy
hitter clip is one that we will take the
whole day to produce and build because
we want to give it special attention and
be really thoughtful and strategic about
how we roll it out the third is that we
built a slide deck that takes this
concept that we summarized in a cartoon
on LinkedIn and built it out extensively
for LinkedIn so now people can pour over
this tactical advice step by step and
capture all the nuances of what Gary is
suggesting
[Music]
now I only showed you a few examples of
the micros that we created from this
hour-long meeting but let's take a look
at the total impact this whole library
of content had
[Music]
everyone we knew that was a lot to
digest and it probably seems
overwhelming right now but although you
may be thinking that how can I do this
without a team Gary if you really think
about it Gary actually started doing
this all by himself for 10 plus years
before you got a team Gary so really
what we want to do is empower you to
know that just start with one pillar
piece of content and one micro and just
get going and just test and see what you
like and what works for you or see you
guys the best
[Music]
Darrius started off so well all right
Gary asked us to create a special hey
guys I know that may seem overwhelming
everything that we just talked about we
really don't want you to feel that way
you might be thinking how do we do this
without a team Gary B team Gary beat
Gary B sorry